maybe everybody thinks i'm all this and
i'm the number one guy whatever
at this level but me what's wrong with
me feeling like
i'm even better than what y'all are
saying you know what i'm saying leads to
the run out for cunningham
hey for cunningham
and he puts it in with two hands
cunningham
rises and rips first question i had to
ask for you
and i saw this going through doing a
little research and you bragged about it
a little bit and i need one myself too
but i need to know the story how you
started to cut hair
and how that all started and how many
cuts can you do
so go ahead just just run it run through
it for me please listen so
um i'd say it started
probably seventh grade
is safe it was probably a little bit
earlier than that but seventh grade is
safe
um yeah it started uh me and my homeboys
we needed
we needed cuts nobody tried to pay that
20 every time especially in seventh
grade
uh yeah i was trying to get somebody on
my own so i started cutting hair
and i was horrible at first and shout
out to my homeboys they
they they had to fight for me because it
was some bad cuts early on
i'm saying now i'm saying you know how
to you know how to cut then
it's just like riding a bike like once
you learn it it just applies so
i can do all the cuts now i know how to
fade i know how to do all that i don't
where do you think this um this
confidence and maturity and and uh
like where did it start form with you
like where did you think that it came
from and how is it instilled in you
um i think the biggest thing like i've
i've been blessed to have people
in my life that have tried these things
before me yeah i'm saying
and and were willing to give me their
knowledge about it
and i think the best thing i did growing
up was just listening to
people ordering having a big brother
that was you know
in college tried overseas um my dad he
went to college and had an injury that
ended his
playing career so it's been different
things i've been able to see
and hear about growing up that you know
i just tried to apply to me and
and i've been blessed to be able to you
know make it to this point without any
any fault so yeah i try to just keep a
level head like
you know it's it's i've seen my dad is
you know a perfect example of somebody
that you know had it going and then
everything went away so you know it's
having somebody like that as the head of
the household
you know raising you just i'm blessed to
have that for sure man he you know he
will have him right
you know you think about my mom pops and
everybody like that like did
how much does it mean like what's the
motivation having them supporting you
like
they are now uh to keep going further
yes i mean it's everything they've been
here since
you know the first game you know i'm
saying and before that so
um you know having people that you know
really know you and and
you know care about you outside of the
game is important and and it definitely
drives me
i got my daughter riley c you know i'm
saying she's growing up that's even more
motivation for me so
um it's exciting for sure i'm excited
for yeah how is
speak about riley like how has
fatherhood been for you
and then also how is it you know what
who is
the father that you envision yourself to
be like you're striving to be as well
i think the biggest thing is is
instilling confidence but like
it's hard to word it i don't want to
teach my my daughter happiness
you know i'm saying like like i don't
want to feel like you know
everything is always all jolly like you
know i'm saying
everything's gonna make you everything's
gonna be the way you want it to be
i feel like you know teaching people
right and wrong and
and you know making people fight through
adversity and things like that
make people work for you know a reward
and things like that you know those are
the things that
i'm excited to do like i have a problem
saying no to her already so
finding these type of things to do for
her it's gonna be tough for me because i
would have buyer everything already off
the roof so
yeah it's tough for swords where was the
moment that you remember like yo i
i fell in love with basketball like i
really want to do this this is what i'm
committed to doing
i'd say probably going into ninth grade
is when
it all clicked like eighth grade this
was the last
time that i played football um and
football football was tough just because
like i love football but i love playing
games
for football like i'm not trying to get
out in that texas sun
eventually i dropped football and then i
loved basketball
double tripled all that it brings me to
another point too because you talked
about
coming into last season you know sort of
feeling like
you were a little bit overlooked in a
way which i know
may throw some people off because if
they look at my dress
but you're you're speaking to something
else can you talk about that too
right and i seen i've seen people saying
like
like bro you're already number one and
people have to realize like it's all
about perspective though at the same
time so like
like okay i i always want to play at
humble though you know i'm saying
maybe maybe everybody thinks i'm all
this and i'm the number one guy whatever
at this level
but me what's wrong with me feeling like
i'm even better than what y'all are
saying you know what i'm saying
like i wanted to get to a point where
people watch full games of
okay just because they know like yeah
he's one and it's not just cutting on a
little highlight tape you know i'm
saying so
yeah yeah i still felt like i was
underrated just because i didn't
really have people's attention people
just kind of knew who i was
i mean it's also like your ability to
want to be coached right like
uh your high school coaches have said
that too it's just like accepting
criticism right i mean you've you hear
that from
um like the tim duncan's and all the
other of the
the greats that they didn't mind being
coached
um was there for you like how did how
did that also become like comfortable
with
taking criticism from you know coaches
trainers whatever it is of just like yo
this is the best for you we're looking
out for you like how did that you get
comfortable with taking criticism as
well
yeah it started because my my fam like
my
my brother and sister they'll tell me
off the rip like
if i if there's anything wrong just with
anything in life so
if you are always hearing that from now
like whenever i hear from somebody else
you know outside i'm not i'm not gonna
put too much weight on it just because
you know it's normal to me i've been
blessed to have
big-time coaches like coach budd and my
bird like he's
the real deal i don't think there's ever
been a better high school person what he
is
so to have somebody like him you know
like he's not afraid to coach anybody he
just wants what's best for he's trying
to you know make
real connections with you and help you
um you know it's easy to it's easier to
get coached by guys after that
coach mike at osu um he was more like a
just somebody that was like a big
brother in the coaches road like
you could talk to him about anything you
connect with him if you don't like
something you could tell him he's gonna
see what what he can do to fix it but he
always maintain leadership
and having guys like that around you
know growing up with coaches like that
it's like it's easy for me to get
coaches because i'm being coached by
good coaches
where else any part of your game are you
like proud that you've seen the
development and growth
um last couple years it can be you can
take it back how far you want but
where are you really proud of you've
made a lot of improvement in definitely
my
my jump shot for sure i feel like that's
probably the the loudest point where
like
you know that's probably the main one
that pops out of the screen like oh he's
doing that a lot better now but
it's been fun you know just being able
to to grow into
more and more of a primary ball handler
and creator um
and i feel like that's the thing that i
think i've had the most fun with and
enjoyed the most about like this whole
journey getting to this point is like
seeing myself go from somebody that was
you know a real life road guy
and just trying to you know set good
screens and
rebound get us you know just just do all
the right plays to
turn into the guy where like you know
i'm saying i'm trying to make every play
now
and i'm trying you know it the the
responsibility
just grew it more and more so that's
thing that you know
i've been the most excited about and i'm
excited to see how it looks
going forward you know in the nba and
just seeing how that grows for sure
are you leaving from you know local high
school and going
to mount vernon like that's a sacrifice
in a sense right because you're leaving
everything you've known to go somewhere
you're not
so i mean to that point even like can
you talk about
the sacrifices that you've made along
this basketball journey to get to this
point now
man i think that was probably the first
big one was
was leaving bowie to go to my birth like
man it's so crazy when i get out there
so it's my junior year when i get out
there
i'm i'm 16. and i turned 17
like couple months or a couple weeks in
so
leaving everybody everybody you ever
known like this is the first time
i haven't been around anybody there's
nobody in the whole state that
i know so i'm kind of just going into
this situation just hoping for the best
and mighty this was so crazy a lot of
people probably won't believe this coach
boyle had never even seen me play
basketball in person before i got there
so i'm just going out to fact the
assistant coach coach ray he's seeing me
and i'm going out to fact like i think
i'm nice so you're gonna have to you
know what i'm saying you're gonna have
to respect it out of the way
yeah so i'm going in yeah i'm saying
like
and then back home things just started
the it felt like crumble like whenever
you're not around
and you're not there to see things
happen you're just hearing it from afar
it feels like everything's going bad i
started having
now i'm saying deaths in the family and
stuff like and everything's hitting me
way
harder whenever i'm you know miles away
from my film so
it was tough for sure but it's it's
crazy like
i wanted to go home so bad i'm steady
calling my mom's like mom's just let me
come home
please just like i'm begging her to let
me slide back to the crib but
yeah it's crazy how much it helped me
and i'm glad i did it for sure and
going into college was so much easier
because i was already used to being
on my own and and trying to make things
happen for myself
clearly like arlen's saying your
hometown meant a lot to you so like what
how did it also shape you as just who
you are skade
like that's that's where everybody's at
it's and what's crazy
it's not even as much about like you
know
missing home but it's missing home and
then
trying to still get in the gym every day
and put your work in
and still be first in every sprint and
still you know what i'm saying
like that's that's the part that's tough
for guys whenever they get out to my
bird or whatever
you know that separation gets tough and
then whenever things get hard for you
and you
see some adversity you know you start
missing home that's whenever you usually
get to
be at the crib and take some time off
but
you know you're gone you're at my
birthday you can't you don't really have
that so
you know i i didn't realize how much i
needed arlington
until i left and then i'm like that's
why that's everything it took me so
yeah it shaped me man maybe who i am
today i'm born and raised over there so
yeah home for sure so what i want to
know is
your mentality with uh picking in the
spots and
and taking over games what is kate's
mentality with
taking over games for me every game i'm
trying to eat you know i'm saying
like obviously i'm going into every game
wanting
50 or whatever but obviously
game plans things like that it's not
it's not as easy as that so
i know i'm gonna leave my mark on every
game and like that
like i go into every game knowing that's
a given like i'm gonna do something
like you know i'm saying other team
gonna know why they say what they say
about me
and and every game it just felt like the
first half was slipped away
from me a little bit like i'm trying to
make things happen or whatever
and the first half will slip and i'm
like i got to do some work in a second
every time and there were some games
where you know things were
going easy for me in the first half or
whatever but
yeah it was yeah i wish i would turn up
a little bit more and then
and then the narrative started going
whatever you know he only turned up in
the second half so
you know how i go but yeah how did that
approach
like get so instilled in you with like
doing what it takes to win because it's
hard
it's like sometimes like you said you
might be off but you know when to take
over the game
sometimes you might be flowing you got
to know when to pick your spots and
everything but to win the ball game you
have to do a lot of things to win
so like how did you get to that point i
think the big
i think the main like beginning for me
was the
texas titans um i started playing in the
fourth grade so
like now i'm saying we're young when we
started this
and then we're winning games uh and we
were tough like we're
nationals we're doing all the stuff that
you know i'm saying these young teams
are going whatever
and you know i think the biggest thing
for us was our togetherness like
everybody knew like the titans their
chemistry was on point
no matter what they're gonna make plays
for each other like they're gonna get
good shots
maybe they might not hit them but
they're gonna make sure they get each
other good shots
and so playing in a system like that
since i was a youngin
and then growing up into that and then i
started getting better and better and
better
like i was still used to playing that
type of basketball so
um eventually it just carried over i
guess it leads into
um you with your leadership as well
because they also say that about you
everywhere you've been with mountain
bird and or even
you know oklahoma state um and even some
of your teammates is always about
like he always has a control
over the game and like a comp and they
listen to you right so when you speak a
lot of your teammates will make sure
they trust you so you think that also
has something to do with that
like how comfortable you are with
leadership yeah definitely
definitely and i think i think that
mainly helps me with like whenever i'm
new to a room
i don't i don't ever feel like you know
a room sways me into
you know going with the the majority i
feel like that's
that's the main thing that my parents
have you know really instilled in me and
then
after a while whenever my name started
to blow up and things like that
um i think the most important thing was
just not trying to force things on
like i feel like a lot of times you know
somebody might be the most known or the
best player and they try to force
leadership on guys and stuff like that
and it's not like a lot of times dudes
are like bro you just doing too much
trying to
you know what i'm saying maybe boost
your head up or whatever so
um i'm just trying to be natural i try
to be me wherever i'm at
and you know i i know i can hoop so in
practice you have to see me anyway
so i think as time goes on people just
you know naturally start to gravitate
towards me and
you know i try to do a better squad i
got my thoughts too but
i think that's why not you know trying
to force leadership
helps because whenever i make a mistake
you're not gonna wanna
bash me for it you're gonna wanna help
me just like i wanna help you so
i think that's probably the main thing i
think that's why my team has been pretty
good
did some of that have to do with just
the 2020 class in itself
like because of how um talented
that you know that at least we view it
and i view it as as deep as it goes you
think somebody also had to do with
your class you were in as well
definitely i think we
i'm so glad that i'm in the 2020 classes
because of the way that we pushed each
other like
and camps um you know everything we just
we pushed each other to a different
level that
like we were friendly with each other we
had fun but
i think you can ask anybody that ran
camps
with us or anything we never whenever
you know
saying we were scrimmaging or or
whatever we never
played friendly like we were always
pushing each other we always competed
and i think that's that's why you know
we've at the 2020 class we all went to
college we performed well
you know what i'm saying people are
excited to see what we do at the next
level just because
like we've been competing hard for a
long time so
it's carrying over like those things
don't happen by accident the aspirations
um along this whole journey right you've
had them but now being this close to
like what is the nba player
that you're hoping to become
the best i'm trying to be that dude
i want to be the best point guard if
they list me as a point guard of all
time the best whatever you want to call
it
um yeah i want to be home like i want
whenever
dudes think of nba they think
cunningham is yeah one of them so
yeah and i'm excited for it i'm i think
the biggest thing is like you know
i've already went through the high
school thing in college thing that's
like the you know the amateur
you know amateur basketball whatever and
being able to see myself next to number
one ranked or you know i'm saying
whatever was cool but now that
you know i'm saying i really get to to
play against dudes that i didn't you
know idolize growing up or
you know just been studying their games
or whatever have been able to compete
against them
i'm excited it's gonna be fun for sure
and then
now my name is i hop into this league my
name is
is like it's hot but it's there's
nothing compared to some of these dudes
so
you're not really turning up you feel me
so it's lit yeah no that's for sure